So how do we test out how our
desktop application works with a touch interface if
we don't have a mobile device handy? Well
it turns out that Chrome developer tools let us
use the mouse to emulate touch event support
on a non-touch desktop. Just open up the
Chrome developer tools, go down to this gear
down at the bottom And under Overrides, select Enable,
and Emulate touch events. Now, close the overrides, but be sure to leave
the dev tools open, you can minimize them to get them out of
the way. And now, as you move across your interface you'll see the
cursor represented by a small dot, this is emulating a touch event cursor.
[MUSIC]
And clicking the mouse is the same as pushing your finger down, or
lifting it off. Now, you don't want to rely on this too much, it
isn't perfect and it isn't exactly like having a real touch interface. So be
sure to test on a real touch interface and a mobile device as well.